so yeah welcome everyone a let that you
made it here I mean it so yeah more
people did not expected really
and I hope you are all a new to
scikit-learn will make it more
interesting I hope it's an introductory
tutorial and I will tell you what today
a little bit about scikit-learn give you
some examples for how you do corrected
modeling and yeah I think not everyone
has a notebook or laptop with them or
and I have the Jupiter notebook oh you
don't have to really execute it in
parallel what I'm talking we will walk
through it together and um yeah we'll
just see how it goes and yeah just to
quickly introduce myself my name is
Sebastian I'm originally from Germany
but yeah yesterday I just came from
Michigan which was almost convenient
I've been at Michigan State for almost
five years now I would say yeah uh
what's a three or four hour drive but
I'm happy that I've made here yesterday
night it's unfortunate okay so then let
me that's a start so just a few infos
here so I get up material of the
material on github if you want to check
it out later on maybe as a reference or
something like that
and if you'd like to contact me my email
address website Twitter github account
in India what have you and um I think
because it's an introductory tutorial I
thought it would be cool if we can maybe
ask a few questions and have a little
bit of a back-and-forth maybe not too
much but I think because I mean I don't
want to give the lecture here it's
really more like a tutorial so if you
have questions then please raise your
hand and we will maybe hopefully discuss
this a little bit and um I'm not sure
how many of you have used machine
learning or psychic learn yet Oh too
many so I hope it will not be too
introductory but um for the ones who
didn't raise their hands um what is a
rockin machine learning do for us so I
plan to insert many more pictures here
but it's always a little tricky with the
copyright and yeah public domain stuff
so what can machine do fast machine
learning I think is everywhere nowadays
we have it I think it started maybe with
a spam filter in our email clients and
with Netflix where we can search for
movies
learns by our tastes what movies we like
makes hopefully good predictions or
recommendations then the automated ATMs
where you have some sort of text
recognition or image recognition and
also know the self-driving cars I found
this little although a cute one from
Google well yeah hopefully it's maybe
the pinnacle of the technology right now
machine learning that we have
self-driving cars which are more or less
hopefully reliable we will see in a few
years so that will play out and so it is
basically just these are just a few
examples what machine learning can be
used for and but what is machine
learning really and machine learning is
just the automating young tasks that we
usually did by hand for example we had a
programmer he looked at what she looked
at a lot of data came up with some rules
and implemented these rules for example
in email spam classification the person
looked at up words that are commonly in
spammed occurring in spam email what
words are occurring not in spam email
usually and then you write rules and
experimented with it and things like
that and nowadays um can we have
powerful learning algorithms so we just
get our algorithm a set of labeled data
we give it maybe 10,000 or 100,000
emails that are spamming us and maybe 1
million non-spam emails and it will
automatically learn rules to classify
them and um yeah there are three big
types of machine learning we have a
supervised I'm supervised and
reinforcement learning and supervised
learning is just for example this email
example we have labeled data we have we
know the output already so we have
emails we know that it's a spamming it
or not and in unsupervised learning we
want to discover a pattern for example
clustering and others we want to you
don't know anything about our data but
we want to find it hidden structure in
it and also maybe we want to compress
all that we see some structures in it we
can maybe break it down into a smaller
dimensional subspace to maybe increase
the learning speed or accuracy also the
storage space and yeah reinforcement
learning would be for example the
self-driving car a chess computer
maybe the go engine that was pretty
popular last couple of months
it's basically learning by doing so
there's a reward in the environment and
system learns incrementally by taking
actions and then getting a certain
reward of a certain number of steps I
think today we will focus more on
supervised learning because yeah we only
have 120 minutes I think so we will have
a reasonable coverage of at least one of
these areas we will talk about mostly
supervised learning and when we break
down supervised learning we can
basically say the big three categories
are regression analysis and
classification in regression analysis we
have a continuous output variable so we
have a continuous input or a binary
input and then we are want to predict a
continuous output variable data
classification we have hard labels we
have there so you can think of it as
categorical filled named labels that are
nominal there's no order in the labels
we have for example class one plus two
plus three
but unless it's a ranking algorithm
there is no can say class 2 is greater
than one it's basically like categories
you can also think of it as names or
something like that and unsupervised
learning like I said before we have our
cluster analysis and yeah progression
dimensionality reduction and clustering
we want to find groups of similar items
or similar samples and in compression we
want to find the structure so that we
can break it down into smaller parts or
than smaller subspaces this example I
just proved this lower right it's an
example of a concentric circle data set
was a synthetic data set and here I use
the dimension reduction algorithm I
think I use thermal PCA to reduce it
onto a one dimensional substrate I mean
the ident label the yxs you to indicate
that it's a just a one dimension here as
you can see it nicely separates similar
agents from each other so that we could
use a linear classifier to separate that
side view from red
and yeah we will look into this in more
detail later and I think we should maybe
start with a linear regression example a
simple linear regression because it's
maybe the simplest introduction I would
say the smoothest introduction so you
probably all of you used a linear
regression so but it is all about we
want to model the relationship between
two variables we have a explanatory
variable and dependent variable and what
we basically a response variable and
what we basically want to do is we want
to find a linear fit that can capture
basically but maybe a trend in the data
so that we have an X variable and input
variable we want to put break the output
variable and we want to learn basing
this dotted line there we want to derive
this woman from the data and how we do
this is by minimizing the vertical
offset so we want to find the line that
minimizes the distance from the line to
other points the vertical distance and
the different protesters include this so
in statistics we can use there's a
closed form solution where you have some
matrix inversion but machine-learning
usually you use some optimization
algorithm it's more meant for yeah
working with big data sets where you
maybe can't really invert the matrix
because it's computationally expensive
for memory or not feasible and so that
is basically just a simple example of
what we can do with machine learning and
how we represent our data also in
psychic learn later will be relevant
this then we have been X usually an
accelerator use usually numpy rates
because we can start numpy array stores
items in a contiguous memory which is
more efficient we can make use of our
memories of other caches l1 and Su cache
and it's just faster to buffer and if
you're from contiguous memory rather
than accessing a live our items or items
in the list of randomly like enough
Python this
I mean the memory access is written so
and we have a lot of powerful linear
algebra functions implemented in our
psychic learn while numpy which also
makes use of the Blas unit of our
computer makes everything a little bit
more efficient that's maybe why we use
mostly numpy for linear algebra and
machine learning rather than Python
objects like lists and yeah in the data
representation when we have our
accelerated is basically our data we
have multiple samples and we represent
them as rows and our features are the
columns in this data rate so it's
usually a two-dimensional array and we
also have in supervised learning a wide
array in the wide array we saw the class
labels of in regression example we saw
the continuous target variable and each
for example each index here 0 1 2 3 they
correspond to the samples in the x-ray
so 0 1 2 & 3 and the columns again are
the different features for example later
we will also work with the iris Lita
flower set where we have different
flower measurements for example petal
with a little length and these would be
features and so the basic workflow of
machine learning um
how we do supervised learning data set
with samples and labels here on the on
the left and what we want to do is we
want to split our data set first usually
want to do random subsampling or
resembling new so we split our data set
into two parts a training set in the
test data step usually it's a maybe two
to three split I was 70% training data
30% test data but it really depends on
how big our data status and the test
data that it's the important part that
we don't touch it during training this
is just for relating the model later on
so we don't want to have our algorithm
look at this data because then we'll
become biased and overly optimistic if
it already has seen this so we want to
keep it secret from our algorithm
just for the evaluation and in the
second step so we take the training data
we use the machine learning algorithm
and learn a model of the predictive
model for instance and I indicated here
or hyper parameter values and we will
talk about that later a high performer -
parameter type of program however
because of the high bosom for example
the number of iterations of our eyebrows
and goes through the data and later on
we will also see for example mature but
right included it but let's say
regularization to introduce a bias by us
to prevent overfitting but half of
American values are basically the values
of our algorithm and not the model
parameters model parameters would be
weight coefficients or the intercept
these would be model parameters for
example here on the y axis this
intercept term that would be a model
parameter that we learned from the data
and also house keep the curve visits of
the coefficient of weight parameter this
is something the learning algorithm
learns from the data and hyperbolas are
something that we as a programmer or
data scientists have to set manually and
we will also see later that there are
different methods that we can for
example a grid search and automate this
looking for these four good values but
it's not learned by the algorithm itself
so in the third step here we basically
use our test data then so we have fitted
the model in step two and we take our
model the in green we have the test data
and we make predictions on the test data
without knowing the labels yet or the
item dozen or the labels so we predict
the labels and then we compare these
labels to each other and see how how it
performs so we compare the labels to the
true labels and predicted labels to the
ones that we withheld
before and then we can prepare how many
mistakes did the model make and based on
that we can on computer certain
performance there different performance
metrics we will talk about this later I
think and in step four after we
evaluated on model there's actually no
reason why we should not also show the
test data to the i/o them because the
testator the purpose is to really
compute the performance or estimate how
well it will do in the future an unknown
new data that has been sampled from the
same probability distribution as of our
training data but once or I will move
but once we evaluated our algorithm
there is no point in with loading it
because usually the more data of the
argument has the better it performs we
will later also look at learning curves
which is an indicator that algorithm may
benefit or not benefit from additional
data so now we can instead for up the
evaluation we can take our whole data
set and use the same learning algorithm
that we have related to form and learn
the final model so let's use the same
settings as before but here we use more
data which is usually resulting in a
more robust model and then yeah
yeah we will talk about that later so
the question was if we do this basically
in one step or if they are most four
iterations that we learn different
models and if you like different models
yeah that's a good point and we will get
to this later when we look at how we can
optimize our hype operator settings but
if we are only at the training and test
split I wouldn't recommend this because
you can easily do it over fitting if you
would really use your training set for
example if you would change the type of
method and step two and relate the
performance again and then you would
change it again and evaluate the
performance again then you would
basically incorporate your test a tech
nerd training procedure so you would
optimize your module also kind of
towards the making good predictions on
test data and this is kind of yeah
cheating I would say so your estimate
here it would not be I'm that unbiased
and also you introducing bias it would
look better than it really is basically
but we will talk about I translated so
this is basically the the simplest work
for when you already when you for
example in scikit-learn use the default
parameters and you just know what I
presume you want to use you don't want
to compare algorithms with the simplest
workflow where you provide the non
algorithm I have a positive value
setting and just iterate the model and
yeah I've prepared some code examples
because yeah it's in a hopper
scikit-learn tutorial not only just
about machine learning concepts so I
hope it is I can make it bigger I think
so hopefully it works here
so we'll also use a matte red lip and
tang us a little bit as they are
convenient libraries that can help us
with visualizing our results and panas
and I get a lot for working with
pre-processing data if you collect data
from different sources and you want to
combine columns or merge datasets it's
all cleaning up the data set find - a
very convenient for that but for the
main machine learning data input for
second where we usually use a nun pipe
so first we will work with the linear
regression example and I don't I don't
know I didn't want to use the Boston
data sets again I think it's a very
popular data set but it's kind of boring
already so I just did a search online
what kind of data sets are available for
a simple regression example for this
data set that compares the relation of
the brain as the size of the brain to
the size of the head so is there a
relationship between a head size and
great size which is kind of interesting
so how this data set looks like is we
have two classes no it's a regression
example sorry so let me see what it
looks like so these are the last five
rows of the data set we have 137 samples
or 36 think and we have the head size
that's a continuous variable and in yeah
cubic centimeters and we have the brain
weight in grams which is also a
continuous variable and we want to use
pay for example that can we use the head
size to predict for the brain weight
would be for example one question we
could ask could we build a model that
can break the brain weight based on the
head size and how this data set looks
like if we just put a scalper I think
pop the question oh yeah sure
think
all right so I always find it helpful to
first visualize the data set to just
long it's not always so easy because
usually we are working with high
dimensional data sets but if we have a
2d data set or maybe the three dead
agents that we can easily do a scatter
plot and if it's more than 3d we can
maybe do multiple histograms to just get
a quick idea for the data set looks like
if it's even if it even makes sense to
build a model on that if for example the
data is completely random there's some
we don't see any correlation I mean it's
probably not a good idea to build a
model because it probably won't work we
can still try but it gives us at least
some idea what we are working with and
in this case it looks like this we have
on the x-axis expiratory well remove the
head size in cubic centimeters in the
brain weight is what we want to put it
in grams and this is our data set that
we will use to build a simple linear
regression model and I don't know but I
think this looks pretty nice or
correlation here I haven't wanted
fighted here in terms of R or R squared
but it looks to me very arm correlated
on a per a gap correlated and to prepare
the data sets so usually I said we are
using non PI plus I could learn we use
maybe tennis because it's convenient to
read the CSF of that CSV file in here or
in this case it's a text file where the
cabins are socialized it's like a
certain number of white spaces um but I
think it is yes so more community to use
tennis for that numpy CC reader can be
sometimes a little bit tricky but once I
could learn we want to convert it now
into the vampire race so by our values
attribute of tennis we can access or an
umpire or underline numpy array you can
think of tennis we build on top of
numpad with a few the top of pandas with
a few extra or convenience functions so
first we will arm access the yeah the
one at 8:37 our class little continuous
output this is now an umpire ring
and then we do the same thing for the
head size and one important thing when
we work with scikit-learn
so when we do we just convert the get
the numpy array from our head size
column will be will be a one dimensional
array so there's only a number of rows
we don't have the second X's here and
for scikit-learn it's important a love
box arise if we want pay attention to
this so numpy expects a two dimensional
array so we have to in this case because
we are here at one column we have to use
for example we can use nine year or
numpy new axis to add a second access to
our numpy array so that we have on the
one or 37 rows and one column so that
it's a numpy array of two x's that's
important too for compatibility with the
second word no chance
so any other questions so far yeah
officially the body for the baby
not much hassle to just use this values
attributes you get the multi rate I
would recommend it it's not always
necessary but you can get a thing I've
seen some cases where let to box when
you use the pandas array directly
ah you mean
hmm so you mean for example the x-ray
only has the the columns but not the
names of the columns so only the index
so usually um you have to maybe keep you
can make a dictionary maybe if you want
to know the names later but yet for
example the columns of a tree good and
if you use all of the columns you could
also just use the index for example in
this case you can use a brain wait the
index later on
I usually just keep track of it when you
do the conversion you have a table and
we can later maybe make an a do an
example where we compute feature
importance and then method back to the
actual labels where we only have called
indexes indices and then we can maybe
get the labels from pick from the
Tennessee River okay at the end maybe
make an example it would be nice one
okay so now we have our numpy arrays a
continuous variable and why that we want
to predict and one continuous variable
in the x-ray one column and yeah the
first step we want to split our data set
into two sub data sets the training data
set in a test data set so there is a
convenient function of the test of train
tests with a function and scikit-learn
and here we can either set the train
size attribute parameter to point 3
which will then put 70 percent of the
data into the extra data set and 30
percent of the data into the training
data set and here I use the random state
I think for like scientific experiment
sets thing recommended so you can
reproduce your results so if I do the
split it will always result in the same
split if I use the same random state and
um maybe I can just show you it's a
smaller array now so we have 237 samples
to start with after the splitting we
have for 70% of 165 samples and how this
looks like is like this we have all the
blue ones are the training samples and
the rest rent
are the test samples of squares and what
I wanted to show you a thing here is
that it's a random split so what happens
it's also a shuffling it which is also
important that we for example not only
take this lower part it's training set
and the upper part is tested to adjust
the shuffling for us already yeah and
then we can fit a model so in a linear
model sub-module of scikit-learn
we have several linear models for
classification and linear regression
will only use the simple linear
regression one without any
regularization and how this works is we
initialize a object linear regression
model that we are object that we will
fit to get our breakup model and in
supervised estimators like a linear
regression we provide both the X train
or in Y train the labels and the
variables and then we can make a
prediction by other predicted method and
it's the basic workflow for
classification and regression in
scikit-learn it's a very nice API of the
fit method to learn the model parameters
and then you use these moderators to
make predictions on the test set and so
we will I think look at it in a second
but all you can maybe you can do it like
this ah sorry the question was if we
call the fit method it will it modify
our our model so what's the question
right so yeah so this is basically here
a blank on blank object with a certain
attribute set not are not assigned yet
and if we call fit it will get certain
attributes like the intercept term or
coefficient so for example it should
have think this one no this is our slope
of the linear regression model and in
scikit-learn by this angle score the
trailing unalloyed it basically
indicates these are
attributes that are available after
model fitting I think so for example if
I would do it like this there won't be
any coefficient I think yeah so there is
no object coefficient so this will only
become available after fitting going to
evaluate our model here how well does it
fit our data scikit-learn you for
classifiers and regression or estimators
they have a score function and for
classifiers we'll see later this for fun
or the score method is using accuracy a
symmetric and for regression models it
will use the determinant of coefficient
of the coefficient of determination so
the R square score and yeah I just
computed it manually just to check that
we get the same results as a
illustration so the linear regression
our estimators all of them inside it run
when you call score it will compute the
are to score which is here on computer
based on the X test and whitest label of
the whiteheads labels it tells us on
there's a pretty decent of variance
explained by the model it's of course
are perfect the score ranges from zero
to one but I would say it's a free okay
depends on your expectation of prospect
on young you what I showed above the two
terms that are no available the slope of
the regression line and the y-axis
intercept and here just to illustrate
how our linear regression fit looks like
so I just took on the so this's and see
so the prediction is basically done by
say where C is our y axis
and let's say a is our input data and V
is our coefficient by this equation we
can compute or make a prediction on new
samples and here I just use the min
value of our training set or Max value
to draw a line between those two points
to illustrate how or regression fit
looks like and yeah cause it's a linear
regression we have some deviations here
from the linear regression line but I
think it's a pretty decent fit in this
case there may be some outliers here
this one maybe that may drag the line in
a certain way a little up and things
like that but overall yeah this is just
an example of how to use scikit-learn
moreover I mean using the fit method the
predict method and the score method to
evaluate or model just earlier so before
we go to the next section are there any
questions I hope it I thought it was
introductory tutorial so I hope it's
actually easy here yeah um yeah so I
just yeah I just showed you the us away
so the question was if I could explain a
little bit more about the scoring
functions available in scikit-learn
so in this case I only showed you the
default the dot score method and in
scikit-learn we have multiple uh scoring
metrics we have Wi-Fi here by the way
also one second
so in scikit-learn there's a matrix or
module I think and they list several
different performance metrics that you
could use alternatively when we do the
proper permit attuning example later I
also will show you how to use this in
during the during the model selection
so you would have to I think I don't
have internet here but I'm not sure to
get a list of all these performance
metrics in the metrics module for
example the our score is also available
through the metrics module so if there
are other ones for example think should
be a mean square error one maybe it's a
spelled a little bit differently but
they have for regression also different
are different scoring functions here in
the metrics module you can exist a
cross-validation yeah we'll get to that
towards the end of the section I just
want to give you a brief overview of how
the estimator works and drill bit with a
fit method the predict and the score and
then later we will talk about
cross-validation which is I think a very
important then let's maybe get back to
so that was just a quick overview to
show you the general API of psychic
learner
yeah because it's a second tutorial I
thought I was focusing a should focus a
little bit about the API itself and then
yeah machine learning because you only
have got so many minutes on so just as a
reminder these three functions are the
most essential ones in the supervised
estimators in the unsupervised methods
of estimators we will see later it's a
little bit different but only slightly
and that's all you need to get started
but later we'll also see how we can
choose these cycle parameters and set
different hypothetical values and yeah a
classic example I mean it's maybe a
known to most of you but I think it's
still going into directory for you a
nice data set because of its properties
we can visualize this data set and um
also the scaling of the variables of
this community to explain yeah so we
have a iris data set it's a probably
most of you heard of it but I would
still talk about it briefly so there are
three different flower species iris
setosa
iris virginica still a bit with one um
iris beginni car
should be like this so three different
four species and what we want to do is
we want to use the flower
measurements for example the width and
height of these leaves to prick whether
it's a total versicolor or beginning a
flower and we have 150 flowers in this
data set 50 flowers from each species
and again we represent our data set um
as the features as columns the
measurements of these petals and sepals
and each sample is one row in our data
set and in our way array we have the
labels and so when we use the frame test
split function in the previous section
about regression we just randomly split
our data set and we can also do that
here we have 50 species from we have 50
samples from each species but one
problem is that we slightly shift the
distributional class tables so for
example here we have a 33% of proportion
of each species represented in the whole
data set and if we use the Train test
split function we will slightly alter
this depending on how random split but
it won't be 33% anymore which is rated
here
so what I mean by that is we change the
frequency of all each class a to a
person the true subsets test and
training set so yeah I used a certain
random seed does matter which one but in
this case I got for example 38 setosa 28
versicolor and 34 beginni cup flowers so
it's not all even it's um before we have
50 50 50 and now we have a slightly
different distribution and in the
training set if we just use a random c
and the same for the test that it will
be basically or changing any opposite
direction so we will also then in the
notebook in a few minutes to see how we
can stratify
a split that means that we can maintain
the class proportions I think I think
that's a relatively new feature and
scikit-learn I think it was added in
version 70 point
I think or 17-point oh um and just a
quick recap about the linear regression
that we just did so what happened was we
had a weird only a simple linear
regression example where we only had one
weight and one intercept so we can
picture it as we have one input variable
and then one intercept term and one
weight and we put it through a net input
function so we summed up or we only had
we only had one on us we only had one
input that we multiplied our weight and
got then basically a if we would have
multiple ones we would get a linear
combination of these and for the
classification we use a following
example just a logistic regression
classifier the name is maybe a little
bit confusing it's called logistic
regression but it's a classifier and how
it is different from this linear
regression is that we now substitute
this linear input function a linear
activation function by a sigmoid l-shape
one in this case it's a logistic
function it's one over one plus e to the
minus Z which is a so the exact equation
does matter about what I want to say is
it's a nonlinear function here and
overall this is a generalized linear
model because there's still a linear
dependence between input features and
weights and at the end so we can use
this one to make a prediction about the
probability how likely is it that a
sample has a certain class but we can
also add in a logistic regression
classifier this of unit step function
which will basically just say if our
output of the sigmoid is larger than 0.5
then it will be let's say class 1 if
it's more than 0.5 it will be class 0
and it's similar to the linear
regression here that we compute the net
input but we substitute the linear
function by a sigmoid function and we
add a unit step function to it
yeah but you could also use a linear
function for this point five split if I
draw it like here if you you think of
the process an x and y interest as the
intercept you could also say if the
input is greater than zero its class one
if it's smaller than zero it's on does
zero and it would be an added line
classifier and adaptive linear neuron
just been invented or people came up
with it in I think
1950s but the logistic regression is a
little bit more robust because let's say
you have outliers you you can basically
show that it's a posterior probability
so with this one it will just shoot
straight up which you minimize this the
minimization it's a little bit trickier
without lies you have not such a nice
minimize it's also convex function but
it's a directly related to probabilities
so which is a nice property of business
and yeah but you could also use a linear
function here which would be then a
depth of linear neuron but this is not
implemented in cycle it's not used in
practice anymore it has been used think
after to perceptron in the 1950s but you
still use a linear activation function
in certain on your network nowadays um
okay so that was a logistic regression
it's basically also you can use it with
you can run with optimization algorithms
where you optimize the way it's
incrementally while you go over the
training set multiple times and another
classifier we will talk about is a K
nearest neighbors and this one is
different from the logistic regression
and that in logistic regression we give
it a data set it will iterate over the
data set multiple times and we will
learn certain weight coefficients and we
just have to keep these weight
coefficients if we have new data what we
do is we put in for example if we have
three dimensions this X 1 X 2 and X M we
would provide these inputs we have then
three weights and the intercept compute
the net input compute the
sigmoid and blah blah but the point is
we don't have to memorize it we have
don't have to keep the data set so we
just learn on coefficients and we can
throw a training set away and we can
make new predictions and K nearest
neighbor is a different so it's also why
it's called a lazy learner so there's no
hitting or learning step really so all
it does it's a prediction time it will
look up which samples are in the
neighborhood of our sample we are
interested in so for instance if we have
this point this question mark point here
we have to keep the training set at what
K nearest neighbor will do is it uses a
distance metric to see okay which are
the points that are closest to Allah
point in question and in this case we
have five nearest neighbors so we are
looking for the five closest points and
then we make just a majority vote so in
this case I have three three triangles
one square and one cross so the triangle
is the majority in this case I would
other and then also predict this
question Marcus or triangle class in
this distance metric I think the classic
one is the Euclidean distance here I
think it's more the generalized form
little profs key distance if you
substitute a tool here instead of the P
you will get the Euclidean distance and
here it's also important I think a tree
based methods are the only ones that are
not scale or that are scale invariant
but here I mean also no gistic
regression depending on your
optimization algorithm and in K nearest
neighbors depending on your distance
metric you want to make sure that your
features are all on the same scale so in
IRS it's simple we don't have to do much
because it's all in centimeters but
let's say we measured one in inches or
we measured one in miles so the number
would be much smaller and it would
appear much closer to the K nearest
neighbor of you clean distance metric so
if we have a different scales we want to
make sure it's all measured on the same
scale and we will also talk in the
notebook about methods to normalize data
so okay I think we will go to the
notebook now to look at a few examples
so again we use panels to retain our
dataset this case it's a CSV file it's
David is txt but it's a CSV file with
comma separated values and this is how
it looks like at Anna's then we have
here I use this text file here because
we have names in the class column which
makes it more interesting I will show
you in a second how we can deal with
this because scikit-learn expects
integers or s yr8 variables or values so
we have three different class labels for
future columns and the problem knows we
can't really fit it directly into or we
can can't directly fit a model here we
use a label in pointer first so we want
to convert the task is now to convert
this into integers that we can use in
our classifier or to fit all model and
there's one convenient class it's called
labeling folder and here we can like all
estimators we have fit method and the
fit method we'll get the labels from a
unique labels from fake data set and
start another class issue with zeros and
ones
you mean true and false or yeah I think
maybe this would be a overkill to use
the labeling problem maybe could also
use an umpire of where or you could use
um let's say
you mean something like that Oh what
happens if I use
you
Oh
in something like that but also for text
variables you could also if there are
only two of them if I think if it's like
this or something or if you have let's
say 0.5 s and some other values point
0.5 for whatever reason is classier I
think you can also use the
something like that right and I don't
know I think the labeling quota is more
useful if you have multiple strings if
you already have number numbers or only
two of them I would maybe use a simpler
way to do it one advantage I think is
that you can just store this information
and glue inverse but you can also set up
a picture so also you could just set up
a dictionary and use the map function in
the numpy so yeah the inverse transform
would be maybe handy if you do the
prediction and you want to look up what
variable it is later on you can use the
inverse transform
maybe that is also something you could
use for your columns independence array
that you talked about earlier but you
said how do I know what indices refer
back to the columns in the panel's array
think that maybe also one application
that you can feed the columns here and
then you can get indices and then you
can inverse transform the indices back
to columns and get the names yeah I
showed you this example to illustrate ok
or how we convert string variables to
integers but there's also a they also a
couple of inbuilt data sets and
scikit-learn for testing if you I mean
these are not exciting datasets but they
are a data set that are useful for let's
say debugging or testing certain things
or benchmarking and the cyclotron data
sets module has several these data sets
in this case we can also vote the iris
dataset directly and here it will be
loaded and then we have its you can
think of it as a dictionary so it has
then certain attributes the EE SCR will
give you a description of the data set
for example
but there are several different yeah
attributes for example the target is our
class table array the data our features
and we have also the target names and
feature names if we interested in these
ok so to make this um probably little
bit more challenging for the algorithm
and maybe also for visual purposes I
only choose two features for our next
example in this case it will be the
first and second one it would be the
sepal length and the sepal width and
here we have three class labels still
and fifty of samples from each flower
statists zero is setosa one is
versicolor inches virginica
and like I said before maybe you want to
use a stratified spit so what happens if
I just split it from the best-trained
test function like we did before in the
linear regression example you get a
different class distribution in the
training data set for example the same
also for the test set so they are not
33% per class anymore so we can use this
stratify of parameter and give it the y
array and then it will stratify the
split so that we maintain the resolution
in this case we have them 35 dollars
from each class so the whole point why
we want to do it is because we want to
have a representative data set assuming
that our iris dataset has been drawn
from some real-world distribution in a
real world we have really 33 percent of
each species which may not be true but
we assuming this when we have our
training says it's one assumption of
most machine learning I wouldn't make
and we also want to have our test set a
representative of the training set of
course we want to learn something from
transit the training set that also
applies to new data and we expect this
new data to be a similarly distributed
as our model the data all model run form
and yeah now we will fit on logistic
regression classifier and I think
a slide maybe it was a little bit
misleading it's a been a binary
classifier so I said if it's a above a
certain value that will be class one and
below a certain value class zero but in
our state I said we have three classes
not true so if you use default settings
if you would remove for example this
part it would use a thing it's a 1vs1
classifier so it will train three or
logistic regression models one or sit
closer versus the beginni car one was a
toss-up versus versicolor and one for
versicolor versus virginica and then
we'll make the prediction based our
based on the best score of these three
but yeah here I just I don't know I
usually use the multinomial one it's a
soft max regression it's changing the
equation limit so we don't it with don't
have a sigmoid but the softmax function
a later one attached to it so it
generalizes to multiple classes and
gives us meaningful probability still
but it's just a side note and we also
have yeah um I think maybe so the
question is how did I make this choice I
think it's maybe just a personal
preference but if the classes are
independent the softmax classification
algorithm should give you a meaningful
probabilities I think the one versus one
classifier works in all cases but I just
for theoretical reasons I think this
reasonable use soft max here um yes sir
I think I would always maybe maybe that
was a shouldn't have done this but I
think because the scikit-learn um
parameters are reasonable so there
shouldn't be a reason unless there is a
particular reason why you wouldn't use
the default settings they should work
well so if I just do it justive
regression and look at the
parameters misspelled it so there are
different parameters by a set by d4 and
I think they are usually reasonable for
example this is a regularization
operator what we want going to into much
detail so if you set this higher
basically you will decrease the
regularization if it's lower you will it
be biased but usually you don't have to
worry about it in a standard setting
into something we do when we do half of
our attitude and yeah you would have we
have to talk maybe more about it later
when we have introduced k-fold
cross-validation I'm sorry I said one
was this one here it's 1 vs. rest
specifier so what it will do is it would
by default train a logistic regression
classifier that learned basically
predicts the total versus physicalism
versicolor
and virginica and so one versus two
other classes or one versus rest
basically and we'll train three of these
classifiers and make them the final
prediction and they are different the
solvers are just the optimization
algorithms so in this case lib Linea is
a efficient I think C++ library which
will optimize a linear model or learn a
linear model efficiently I just use
Newton's CG I think because the lip
Linea doesn't support multinomial which
I personally like for these cases but
young but anyway so maybe we should
continue um I hope yeah we can talk
about it after the session more I will
I'm happy to talk more about subjects
regression then um okay so in this case
we get a test accuracy of 80% so that
main basically means it classified 80%
of our flowers correctly and we had 105
flowers the 70% of the one are 50
oh sorry in the chest that we had a fear
we have 545 flaws and again like in the
auricular
regression example we have a fit method
to learn the model our coefficient and
we have the score method to make a
prediction and in a linear regression
example it was the R square and in a
classification estimator
it's the accuracy and yeah here I just
important function from one of my my
convenience libraries just to visualize
our classifier looks like and think I
have an old version installed here
you
so yeah this is how our classification
uh looks like the result so we have
three decision boundaries and red are
the total flowers green are the
virginica flowers and drew out the
versicolor flowers and yeah it makes a
few mistakes as we can see there's a
overlap in we only use of sample width
in several lengths so my legacy sure why
it's not showing up here but it should
be a simple length and yeah in this case
we make a few mistakes and I circle the
test samples here and that's how linear
regression model looks like yeah yep
I have so the question was when someone
changes the random seat we will get a
very different result and this is an
effect because on the data set is rather
small and we have a large variance so we
are basically our estimate is sensitive
on to how we split our data so there are
different methods I think I have slides
about that one would be a repeated hold
odd so you would repeat this maybe 15
times do the splitting by each time you
use the different random C and then you
can maybe average the 50 predictions
would be a little bit more robust you
could use bootstrapping it's an for
estimating the uncertainty of you
estimate it's also resampling the data I
think f also slides on that or you could
use a cable for validation instead of a
training test split you quit if you
don't choose the - writers you can also
use it's a 10-fold cross-validation but
I have slide slides about the data to
introduce this with a few more images to
make it more clear and then we do the
same thing with a K nearest neighbor
classifier and as we can see the K
nearest neighbor classifier is we don't
have linear boundaries here and we have
for example of set one parameter here
the number of neighbors - for if I
change it it will also change across the
decision boundary for example if I set
it to let's say something high it should
be smooth on and we will talk later
about how to do this properly how to
choose good type operator bellies and
yeah and one more about tiebreaking so
if I have something like it's very rare
in data sets but if I have for example
set it to 4 and it happens that there
are two and two in two classes for
example in the neighborhood so it can't
make a decision it would just I think
pick the first class from the data so it
depends on how the data set is ordered
so I usually I don't know but I always
pick
big number so to not have any randomness
and Hall of something is picked if
they're so we can also go to the
exercises later but yeah I wanted to get
maybe to the model evaluation because it
was the question that came up multiple
times think that this can maybe do the
fourth section and then go to the sixth
section to talk a little bit or model a
variation yeah also what do we do when
we work with categorical variables so
before we had an example where we have
names in the class label column but what
do we do if we have for example one of
floats or non integers in the feature
column this is a very trivial example
but what I wanted to highlight here is
there are two types of categorical
variables so we have ordinal and nominal
variables so the color here the color
column if this would be a feature this
would be a categorical variable which is
nominal so there's no order implied by
that I mean usually a few exceptions but
usually you can't say red rather than
Google or green is greater than red or
something like that you can't really
order it in this example we talked about
t-shirts for example the size if we
order it it may make sense so we can say
jeez t-shirt size of Excel is great or
bigger than a t-shirt t-shirt size L and
L is bigger than M so we have an ordinal
variable here we can order it and the
same for the price it's already flawed
but it has some weird character in front
but we also can convert it so we have a
nominal variable a ordinal variable and
the continuous variable here and
the class neighborhoods they look like
they are also or maybe if we have class
limits 1 2 & 3 they look like they are
ordinal that we can order them but most
classification algorithms unless they
are for ranking
they don't assume any other in the class
labels but the features there
I wouldn't would assume there's an order
so we can't use for example the labeling
holder if we have a nominal variable if
we would use the neighborhood encoder it
would maybe do something like 0 1 & 2
and then it would imply the green is
bigger than group but there are other
ways to deal with it and I will talk
about it in one second so one would be a
1 how to encoding it's a basically
converting a nominal variable into a 1
what encoding which means like multiple
binary available variables so here we
take a 1 input variable that is nominal
and split it into 3 variables and we
binarize it also so if there is a 1 here
it means that it's a red one and so the
sample is a red the sample is blue and
the sample is 1 so we just binarize it
we make multiple variables out of one
it's one way to deal with it the most
common way and here we don't have to
worry about one hot and cold because we
have an order we can just use for
example label encoder to assign a
numerical values to it but then the
trick is um we as a human we have to
know which one is bigger than the other
ones so I would recommend looking at the
data and doing this manually with a
let's say it's setting up the dictionary
mapping because how does our labor and
father know that Excel is bigger than
else it's something that we as data
scientists have to manually maybe a
verified and then feature normalization
like I said before most algorithms are
sensitive to scale so especially for
example the K nearest neighbor
classifier so there are two common ways
to normalize features one is a min/max
scaling and one is a z-score
standardization on there are other
methods like a two and one l1 norms but
these are
the most common ones so in mimic scaling
we would on its imagined feature is our
example feature on values from 1 to 6
and min max scaling will rescale these
values onto a scale from 0 to 1 and this
z-score standardization in contrast it
will Masek Allah give it the properties
of a standard normal distribution that
it's centered at 0 so the mean of the
feature will be 0 and it will basically
you can interpret it as minus one point
four six standard deviations from the
mean these values it's centered around
the mean which is usually the typical
way to yeah I think usually there's some
no reason why one should be preferred
they are certain exceptions I think in
on people work with images mimic scaling
is more popular but for example for the
K nearest neighbors I think it shouldn't
make such a difference but things ZCO
sanitization would be more on a
maintaining knowledge about outliers
here you would kind of mimics getting
smoothing a little bit out the magnitude
if you have extreme outliers we don't
have them here usually use
standardization for a simple
optimization algorithms such as let's
say gradient descent because you update
update the weights more equally it's
usually also newer networks but there
are also certain ones I think for really
units you use min max skating it really
depends it's sometimes in your networks
empirical they just try different things
another question oh no I think there's
no good reason to avoid it um usually
your variables are very rarely normal
distribute its a just so the goal is
basically just to bring them onto the
same scale so if you have completely
different magnitudes we want to have
something that is centered around zero
and
in terms of standard deviation something
from the minute also tells you something
about your variable and it's also useful
for example if you standardize it and
you do a linear regression with multiple
weights you can kind of see or look at
the weights then of if your input
periods are all the same scale if you
have a linear model it should you tell
you how important are certain features
or how much role it plays in the final
prediction if it's a large value the
weight will be small and if it's on for
example in stencil it really is only
helpful usually in applications and yet
it has a nice property that your data is
centered around the mean which is in
certain applications also for
optimizations I optimization algorithms
are nice property and you have the
positive and negative values so you can
update in both directions whereas mimics
Kaling you own your positive ones um
yeah there's also a class and
scikit-learn
that can do this for us a convenience
function you can do this manually but
there's a convenience function to do
this and when we talk about this I just
want to introduce it very quickly
unsupervised estimators so you can think
of standardization but really as in
unsupervised I wouldn't but it has the
same API so you have also fit method to
use in this case if you do
standardization you would deduce the
mean and the standard deviation from the
data set you will store this and use the
transform method to transform any new
data and then other so unsupervised
estimators they have an addition also a
predict method if you use a clustering
algorithm but thing we won't go into
this in teacher unless we have more time
I always see how we do and then maybe
talk about it more later and just to
give you an idea of a typical machine
learning or a psychic verb pipeline it
is also the pipeline in cyclone it's
also a convenience wrapper that allows
us to put multiple estimators into one
kind of workflow you can think of it as
a workflow so we can see the notebook in
a few seconds so we can put a
estimator for scaling into this pipeline
you can use something for dimensionality
reduction in this paper we will talk
about this in a later and our learning
algorithm and then we treat this
pipeline as an estimator so we also in
the pipeline itself is an object that
also is a fit fit and transform method
so we call it fit on the pipeline and
what it will do behind the scenes this
will fit the scaling estimator pass the
stage on to the next part in our
pipeline pass it to the next one and the
last one it's the last one should always
be the learning algorithm which
basically the Oni has a fit method to
learn the model and then we can have a
it also has a predict method like an
estimator and if it sees test data we
use a click method we'll hit anything
again but it will use the things that we
learn from the training data to passes
down the pipelines apply these
transformations and make the final
prediction I think it will be become
more clear in the notebook it's a little
bit abstract here so let us look at that
one so it's just again an example or to
deal with categorical variables the
example I showed you on the slides so
there's a dict vectorizer for instance
and here we it takes these strings and
converts it to this one hot encoding
here um and it does the same with the
size which is maybe not what we want
like we talked before because there is
an order and also what you know cheers
that it will kind of shuffle the order
of it because it's a dictionary it will
put for example this variable at the end
but that's not important what I wanted
to get it is in such cases where we know
that there's an order for example this
data such as we know excels bigger than
L and bigger than M you maybe can set up
a dictionary manual manually and use map
function
to do the transformation like this that
we can convert the size 1 to the 3 and
then we can vice versa also do the same
thing in verse if you later for
interpretation what you convert it back
can make an inverse mapping dictionary
so what I've done here is basically I
did this step manually and now
everything should find it should look
fine and if we use the dick vectorizer
abalone touch the column that is a
string variable or has a string values
in it which would be color and it will
do the right thing then and do the one
hot encoding on this right or left of
three columns on then briefly the
normalization or example data set from
the slides then we have max scalar and
the standard scale up from scikit-learn
and it has a normal fit method here and
one convenience function it it has a fit
transform a method which is just equal
to we would do this would be equal to
this it's just more convenient just a
shortcut for this now the pipelines
I think that's more interesting and
that's very useful in practice so again
we have our simple Irish data set our
linear regression logistic regression
classifier and this is just a simple
pipeline because I can talked about
dimensionality reduction yet but here um
you can use the make pipeline function
to put two things into one pipeline we
have the standard scale and we have the
logistic regression we could do this
manually we could like before use this
output we can get a new output here and
then let's say can do an X scaled do
this and then put all our gistic
regression classifier in two steps
but I think the badge will become more
clear why this is useful is when we do
cross validation and when we do grid
search to optimize all have apparatus
um because then it will be applied to
each split of the data but you can think
of it as a normal estimator that has
just the multiple elements inside yeah
one question yes so one important point
the question was um I use the if I use
the standardized age or if I use the
parameters from the training data set in
normalization when I normalize the test
data set and yeah this is a very
important point so we don't want to
refit our scaler on the test data set so
if we have let's say a data set that has
values 100 200 and 300 and we use the
standard scalar of the college
although gates then yeah also you see
for your not enough values here but we
get the center around me and a mean and
then one point minus one point two
standard deviations for me so this is
fine but um let's say we have a test
data that is now let's say okay I think
just a reminder it's not really an
actual profile that are you have ten
minutes left
um so one second so if we have for
example let's say something like this
new data and this would be an extreme
outlier so if we would use the fit
method again then we will kind of change
what this zero means it won't be an
outlier anymore so
so it won't be that much of an oddly I
mean here it's an extreme outlier but
here this information gets kind of lost
because you fill it again so what we
want is really just transform it so as
you can see then it's in relation to the
others a much larger value so it's
always a one point what we want to be
careful that we don't use any test data
to fit any parameters in our pipeline
yeah and if we want to use a simple
technologies
okay so here I'll just fit and squat the
pipeline here it's the across the squad
it's just like the logistic regression
but with a standard scale in front and
to access these steps are one question
or can you repeat us yeah I didn't
understand the completely of
yes so the question was when I caught it
correctly so what happens if the train
gate is not representative of the
population and we do the standardization
and then the prediction would be kind of
wrong because you got the wrong
parameters yeah there is a problem I
mean I'm not sure to deal with I mean
like the algorithms you use here they
assume or they work optimally only if
our training set is a representative of
the distribution of the population sorry
so one thing is for example this also
why we want to do the stratification
because if the proportions if with very
small data set and the proportions of
training a test are completely different
then yeah it's not ideal so we want to
it's a parameter estimation problem so
the larger your data set is we need to
show you the law of large numbers the
more closely will your parental
estimation be to the real world
population but this is the one
assumption we have to make it our trains
later set is really representative of
what we want to predict if it's
completely different than you know how
can we learn from that right we have
could have sampled the data set maybe
differently we could have once won a sub
samples but if we don't know the
population parameters I think there's no
way to know how to resample a data set
umm yeah I'm sorry I think took a little
bit longer that I thought we only have
like five minutes left a little bit yeah
so hmm maybe we can talk I mean I will
be here for the next two days if you
want to talk about model information I
am probably not getting to this right
now
uh yeah dimensionality reduction there
are also two ways you can select
features or you can extract features but
yeah you can maybe look at the Jupiter
notebooks and if you have questions I'm
happy to answer emails really because
I'm sorry that I a puzzle a bit slow
here and didn't get to everything and I
already removed a lot of topics nine
minutes is really tough um yeah this was
one question that came up that I will
maybe want to if I answer your question
I want to quickly get to the
there was one point where someone said
you changed the random seed with the
splitting and got different performance
estimates in this result so in here I
did exactly this exercise four on the
Left I split the training data of the
Irish set in 50 50 50 percent of irises
training and fifty percent of irises
test data in this case I repeated this
50 times and as you can see the
difference there's a difference
sometimes I get a 90% accuracy sometimes
a 1% accuracy so usually the smaller the
data set the more pronounced this effect
is and also the smaller your test set is
the more variance you have in your
estimate so for example when I change it
here to ninety ten so 90% is training
data and 10% is test data this variance
becomes larger of the estimate and the
reason is for example it really depends
then more on which exact sample end up
in the test set in which sample ends up
in the training set and one one way a
simple way would be to just take the
average of this and there's
cross-validation K for cross-validation
and loop scraping may be something you
want to also look up later on after the
session which is very useful in practice
and for model selection especially yeah
I forgot of points here but reading
running out of time here um yeah so
maybe on look at this I luckily put it
in here there's one more document on a
psychic learning or documentation where
you can also read about model iteration
but yeah you can I'm happy to answer
questions really and if you want to in
general look at for other resources
maybe on the psychic learning website
would be a good place they are really
extensive documentation about everything
and there's the mailing list I think
people will be happy if you join and ask
questions there are a lot of people
helping people on the mailing list
answering questions also in practice I
find andreas mullahs teach it very
useful so it's a chi chi tips
ask the ask you a simple question
kind of as a beginner guides you through
what I with them should I use on what
kind of data set
maybe something you want to check out
and yeah andreas moolah is also still
writing his book I think I think he said
last time it was finished in July when I
was with him at Syfy but I think it will
be October 20 a call it correctly know
and you will read the final draft and
well the draft the latest round and it's
a really great book it's all about
psychic learn so I think it will be the
definite resource for psychic learn
there are lot of books about psychic
learn but I think that is the most I
would say accurate one he's a a dresser
also psyche blue and co-developer will
be out in get to month for the theory
parts these are my two favorite books
the left one elements of statistical
learning it's a free book I recommend
this this is also maybe my favorite
because it was my first machine learning
pattern classification books years ago
so it has a special place in my heart
but they are both great or they go about
they talk about the statistical
underpinnings of the eye bottoms and
yeah if you're interested I also have a
small book here has also been it's I
think it's Japanese one or if you like
German and this is the original English
one but I have didn't write these other
people translated and so I can't really
vote for them I can't even understand or
can't even read this a lot of fun looks
pretty um yeah so if I have more
resources on the ski table repository
with code examples and like I said I'm
happy to answer a questions later on
again then my email address website
Twitter account github account and the
link to the material if you want to get
the slides or something like that and
yeah that's about it I think and yeah
I'm sorry that it's only 90 minutes I
could have talked about it for maybe
mine hours I was at Syfy with Andreas
last month and we had
seven hours and we didn't cover
everything we wanted to cover it was
still not enough so ninety minutes was a
little bit challenging what I hope
you've got some introduction at least to
get into scikit-learn if you're
interested or maybe have some links to
further resources where you can find
more information and yeah ask me
questions if you like